If you put this skill into Claude,
Claude will do a complete AI search
visibility report that will help your
brand get cited more often in ChatGPT,
Perplexity, and AI search. So, here is
how it works. Once you enter in this
skill, if you'd like to get access to
this skill, just comment AI search below
and I'll send you over the complete
skill. Enter in the skill, your niche,
your website, and then Claude will go
out and do a visibility report. First,
you're going to see where your brand
currently fits in terms of AI visibility
compared to your top competitor. Then
we'll also get a visibility gap to see
how you can improve, topics identified
to the top keywords or queries that we
need to write about to in order for our
brand to get cited in ChatGPT or any
other AI search. So, as you can see
here, we're going to get an overview of
this actual report. And then we're going
to get our visibility matrix. So, it's
going to show you which brands appear in
AI responses for specific queries. So,
we see here because this is a Niagara
Tours company, the query best Niagara
Tours, sorry, best Niagara Falls Tours
from Toronto, we see that in ChatGPT, we
have a couple of our competitors here
and we have not been mentioned. In
Perplexity, we see as well which
companies are being mentioned and in
Google's AI overview again, we see which
companies or brands are being mentioned
and if ours is mentioned. And if we're
not mentioned, this is a great
opportunity for us to go out, create
content or pages around this query in
order for our
brand or website to be shown up. So,
it's going to go through some of the top
and most sought-after queries for our
specific niche. So, best guided tours to
Niagara Falls, day trips from Toronto to
Niagara Falls, so on and so forth. So,
again, if I wanted to cross-reference
this, I can copy over any of the query.
I'm going to head back over to ChatGPT.
I'm just going to enable web mode and
I'm going to enter in that query.
And the brands that show up here are
essentially going to be the same brands
that we got from our report from Claude.
So, this goes through a couple of
different um queries here, but these are
all very, very related queries and again
gives us a great starting point for what
we need to do. We also then get a
competitor intelligence of how often
each brand appears across all queries
and platforms. So, brands with a higher
score have a stronger AI citation. So,
again we see our competitors here, Queen
Tour, Airlink, Seaside, so on and so
forth and we can see how they do uh in
terms of AI search. So, which uh
companies here are getting cited? And
the ones that are getting cited more
often than not are usually the websites
with the big you know, the biggest
websites that we need to um mirror or do
more competitive advantage of. So, this
gives you just better intel so you can
go out and do more competitor research.
We also have our topic roadmap. So, this
each topic is mapped to a specific AI
search query and designed to make your
site uh citable.
So, we see the topic here, then we see
the target AI query, we see the type of
article, we see the gap, and then we see
the GEO angle, right? And we can
actually go ahead and write this
directly onto WordLift. So, what I can
do here, I can copy over this topic,
head back over to Claude, and then tell
it to write the article using WordLift
MCP connection, which I'll show you guys
in just one bit. So, we have an action
plan here. It's a 90-day action plan and
then we have our tracked queries. So, we
can actually
go back over to Claude
and we actually went ahead and used a
new MCP, which is the LLM prompt
tracker. So, this is from mcp360.ai.
All you need to do is essentially
connect your MCP over and then we can
actually track
we can actually track our queries
and how they do on different LLMs.
And as I mentioned before, we've also
went ahead and entered in our Word
Rocket MCP connection. I've already done
a lot of videos on this and if you want
to get the full playbook, again it'll be
in the SOP if you comment AI search
below. But just head over to settings
and then we're going to head over to
connectors, we're going to go to
customize and then we're going to add a
new connector.
A custom connector, give it a name and
for Word Rocket we enter in
wordrocketapi.com.
MCP360, we just select any of the
workflows here, click setup, API key and
then you just copy over this full URL
with your API key.
Into the remote MCP server URL
and you're good to go. So as you can see
this is not just based upon the training
data from Claude, we actually have live
connectors and we're using Chrome as
well to ensure that we're getting the
most
up-to-date information. So what I did
was now I told it to based upon one of
the first queries, so I just told it to
write this article using the Word Rocket
MCP. So it's really really important to
have your Word Rocket connected to
Claude because if we if we tell Claude
to write this article,
more likely than not you'll run through
your usage for that day. But when you're
using Word Rocket, you have a powerful
tool that you can use that's easy for
you to publish your content. And as you
can see here, it literally
read the article and then published the
article directly over to our WordPress
site. So let's go ahead and open this
and see if it worked properly.
Okay, so here is the full article here.
We get a cover image. We get our key
takeaways. We get our introduction here.
And we get our tables.
Beautiful beautiful. We get a couple of
tables here. FAQ, a conclusion with our
tags. So Niagara
tour Sorry, Niagara Falls tour versus
self-drive from Toronto, which is
better? A beautiful beautiful cover
image that we're able to get back here.
Key takeaways, tables, everything.
If I go ahead and click edit post, we
can see that our title and our meta
description as well has been added in
along with our cover image um has been
posted. This is a beautiful beautiful
article with our internal links and our
brand guide as well as you can see.
Internal links, brand guides, beautiful
tables here.
Everything you would want in an article
and we were able to do that auto um auto
automatically using Claude but using the
data that it found and then using that
information to then tell the AI to write
an article with live and up-to-date
information. So this is a very very
powerful process as you can see. You can
grow your AI visibility and get more
brand mentions using this Claude skill.
Hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video. If you did, let it be known by
giving us a big thumbs up and I'll see
you in the next one. Take care.